the jurogan experience not today uh
we've come to this place where uh
if you want to be peaceful you need a
chemical
you want to be joyful you need a
chemical you want to be healthful you
need a chemical
well you want to be ecstatic of course
there is a chemical right
so what is the consequence of this why
this is happening
one thing is in this generation one
thing that's happened in people's minds
is
the heaven has collapsed in people's
minds the heaven yes how so
see uh i've been talking to people 50
years ago if i spoke to people
and i asked how many of you want to go
to heaven almost 80 percent would raise
their hands
today you go to your university and ask
them how many of you want to go to
heaven
they'll say
they think it's a ridiculous question
all right nobody will raise their hand
so in their minds heaven is collapsed
there's no place to go
so they want to do everything here all
right
so they have not found
how to be
joyful and ecstatic within themselves
so
chemical usage initially it became
alcohol then it became chemicals it's
getting stronger and stronger
and
you know so many people
dying of those things every every day
and illnesses and it's costing a nation
in the world a lot it's not just in one
country it's it's going across the world
law enforcement agencies may be
controlling it a little bit but they can
never control it totally because the
consumption is mass-based it is
uh more people may be consuming these
things and people eating bread
it's becoming like that
so
this whole moment where it's going means
if you do not raise human consciousness
if you do not teach people how to sit
here
feeling absolutely blissed out within
yourself by your own nature because
this human mechanism is the most
sophisticated chemical factory
if you are a good ceo
you would produce the chemicals that
will give you fantastic experience
if you're a lousy ceo you're giving
yourself a bad experience
yes now you're buying chemicals from
outside to fix that all right so
essentially you're a bad manager of your
own system you're not taking charge of
this why is that happen because your
education your society is talking about
conquering the world but never taught
you anything about how to take charge of
this do you agree with me the most in
this room there's so much technology
here in this room the most complex and
sophisticated technology is
within your system yes or no human
system yes this is have you read the
user's manual
there's no user's manual there is there
is yes where is it it's built into the
machine oh how do i get it you need to
pay attention you're reading you know
engineering
read that carefully there are i'm
reading it i'm in the middle
i'm at part two there are uh
pointers as to how to read your own
user's manual yes let me take you back
to this concept of heaven you know when
you're talking about uh people in
universities that you say how many of
them want to go to heaven the problem is
they don't have any evidence of heaven
and so when a lot of these young people
that are atheists or agnostics they
don't want to buy into anything that
they believe is connected to fairy tales
or they're connected to some sort of an
ideology that they believe was
manufactured to control people and to
keep people in the chest
collapsed in their minds in their minds
but it's also because
heaven is connected to religion and
religion is connected to atrocities
there's a lot of people that think of
religion they think of the the evils of
the catholic church or they think of you
know what religion has justified the
horrors of history the things that
people have done in the name of religion
so a lot of younger sophisticated
intelligent people don't want to believe
in anything that there's no evidence for
so when you say how many of you want to
go to heaven say show me a video
tell me where i'm going do you have a
map of heaven i am not asking that
question offering a ticket i'm just
telling you heaven is collapsed in
people's mind which is a good thing
because it's a good thing it is because
because the idea
that this is not the place to live well
there is another place where you will
live right
it's a wrong idea right
this is the place to live well you can
have heaven right here yes
and uh who told you you're not already
in heaven and making a mess out of it
um no one
i think that's possible
we are in a heaven making a mess out of
it
right now too whether we want to fix the
soil or we want to fix the human mind
you're only trying to see that you don't
mess up the heaven in which we have
landed yes
i i could agree with that i think the
problem is the term heaven when you say
it people think of a biblical heaven
they think of a place that you go no no
every religion has their own kind of
heaven that's the whole thing i'm saying
before bible came there have been
heavens in other places yes yes
you know one thing i found this is one
thing good about this soil is see people
may even have separate heavens to go to
but we all come from the same soil our
bodies go back to the same soil so this
is a unifying factor irrespective of
one's religion caste creed whatever else
so in your mind this concept of heaven
relates to like a harmony amongst
yourself the in the people the living
things around you including the soil see
essentially it's like this
if you feel pleasant in your body
we call this health yes
if you feel very pleasant in your body
we call this pleasure
if you feel pleasant in your mind we
call this peace
if you feel very pleasant we call this
joy
if you feel
very pleasant if you feel pleasant in
your emotion we call this love
if you feel very pleasant we call it
compassion
if you feel very pleasant in your very
life energies then we call this
blissfulness if you become very very
pleasant then we call it ecstasy
if your surroundings become pleasant we
call it success
so to create pleasantness in the
surroundings
we need the cooperation of people and
forces around us
without everybody's cooperation you
can't create a pleasant atmosphere but
pleasantness of the body pleasantness of
the mind pleasantness of emotion and
energy is 100 your business
isn't it
so if you're feeling
ecstatic you are in heaven
because your idea of heaven is a very
pleasant place isn't it yes
this place this planet earth is very
pleasant except for the human beings who
create creating unpleasantness among
each other well this sounds like a great
concept but human beings are very
complex their emotions are complex their
needs and desires and their trauma and
pain and insecurities and
and all mental health issues how does
one get to that spot like what you're
saying sounds wonderful i mean you're a
guru you're a literal guru so when you
sit here and tell people these things
they go well that sounds easy for that
guy no look at him it's it's not why is
it it's not easier if you've got a great
beard
it is not easy or difficult it's not it
is a question of wrong direction or
right direction that is you went to an
apple tree and you're digging the roots
because you're a potato farmer that is
the only problem you have
you're
you're the source and seat of your
experiences within you
what happens within you should it happen
your way or my way tell me your way or
my way no what happens within you should
it happen your way or my way
well it's within me when you say within
me do you mean my thoughts your thoughts
your emotion your body whatever your
chemistry your energy everything what
happens within you should it happen your
way or somebody else's way well i think
uh if your way sucks maybe you should
listen to other people and maybe try
their way
see if it happened your way would you
keep yourself blissful or miserable you
would keep yourself blissful if you were
wise
if you were wise and your mind was
working properly but if you have mental
health issues that's exactly what you're
if you're filled with trauma if you're
poorly educated you're starting from a
deficit a severe deficit where you don't
think correctly
no no that's not that is not
that is not the problem the original
problem the root of the problem is
let's address one step at a time okay
see right now the simple question is
what happens in your mind your emotion
your chemistry your energies must be
your way isn't it it well it's yours yes
it is yours so it must be your way but
it's not happening your way right now
because it's in a compulsive reactive
state okay
so see anybody can cause anything within
you so if i decide what clothes you must
wear what food you must eat what you
should do every day
you will call this slavery isn't it
the government
don't go there
so uh
right now someone else something else
can decide what happens within you isn't
this the most horrible form of slavery
that someone can decide whether you are
happy or unhappy
yeah that's not good that's not that's
not the best question so the problem is
just this
an intelligence which needs to be
conscious
is unfortunately unconscious and
compulsive
so the only problem that you have is
compulsive reaction to life around you
what is needed is a conscious response
to life
so this simple thing people have not
handled from their childhood
right so when you don't handle this one
thing everything will be wrong
everything will be accidental
your success and failure both are
accidental
so what do you say to someone maybe
they're 30 years old and they've had
this life of
mistakes and
regret and maybe alcoholism or gambling
or some other problems but they want to
be conscious they want to be
blissful they want to be enlightened
they want to be a happy person filled
with love
what path do they take what what steps
do they take to correct the
journey they're on why is why is it
though human beings are not the
strongest creatures on the planet
compared to other species
why is it that human beings are
dominating this world
simply because of our ability to use
tools isn't it
and our intellect our ability to
manipulate our environment yes but even
then if we didn't have
knowledge of using tools right
the buffalos would have mowed us down
all right
yes
so
your intellect they don't care it's your
ability to use tools you made an arrow
you made a gun
you made so many things made a house yes
yes
uh everything all instruments right now
microphone yes or telephone or whatever
else these are all instruments to
enhance
we are this much because of our
instruments we become that much right
now there is one little screw here in
this furniture i will ask you you're a
strong guy i will ask you to unscrew
this with your hands you can't do it you
do it you may lose all your nails i'll
allow you to use your teeth maybe you
lose some of them
it's gonna be a problem but it'll be
right there
but if i give you a screwdriver boom
in a minute you will get it out so this
is the power of the tool yeah so as
there are tools for doing things in the
external world there are tools to handle
this because you don't have a tool kit
this machine which is the most complex
machine is going crazy right now you're
reading in engineering it's a tool kit
yes you just use the tools don't worry
about the philosophy don't worry about
belief system don't worry about your
concept somebody's concepts your beliefs
somebody's beliefs just use the
necessary tools being peaceful joyful
loving is a natural outcome of that
okay well what are those tools like the
scenario that i laid out you have a
person who's 30 years old
they have a history of trauma in their
life they're very unhappy very depressed
maybe they're alcoholics they're trying
to get their life in order
today i want you to understand this the
issue foundation and the senior
engineering process that we're doing
around the world
in 2021 i think 2020 2021 i think it's
2021
our video views are 2.2 billion 2.2
billion video views yes
that's a lot yes why
because it's worked
and because we have
it has worked i'm saying for people yeah
we have over 16 million volunteers
working with the foundation
why are they doing this because the only
reason is it has worked what is it
that's worked i did not teach them a
morality i did not teach them a
philosophy i did not promise them
miracles i did not pull uh gold chains
out of thin air and give it to them
no nothing
simply tools to fix themselves well just
how to sit how to breathe how to manage
yourself this is all yes
you're entertaining you know that's also
one of the reasons why you have that
many views how many views do we have
if you guessed put your pull your mic
down so we can hear you on youtube i
guess yeah let's just go with youtube
no no it's okay
that's all told how many views
[Music]
i don't know say four billion it's okay
no i don't know probably about the same
sounds about right yeah and we don't
we're not teaching you [ __ ]
no that's not true other people are that
are on there but i i think that i i see
what you're saying that it works but
what else
works is what are those tools this is
all very like mystic
difficult for people to grasp there are
there are mystical aspects also but that
is not for everybody but i mean in this
conversation only for those who are
interested in those things who want to
pursue that aspect for the rest of the
people for somebody if their back back
goes away his life changes for somebody
if his headache goes away his life
changes yes somebody drops his alcohol
consumption addiction his life changes
yeah somebody some compulsive thought
that drives him crazy that goes away
these are simple things
this is just a small screwdriver is all
he needs he doesn't need a total
overhaul
mysticism is a different aspect it is
like you're not just interested in
living well you want to know the very
root of life yes that's a different
aspect that's not for everybody that is
only for those who seek that but for
common people all they want to do is
they want to live peacefully joyfully
with some sense of purpose to whatever
they are doing in their lives